"Quick, to the Batcave!"
Dr. Bright cried, reaching for his utility
belt.
But there was no time, he couldn't get his
hand on his grappling hook before the guard
tackled him to the ground.
But how did we get here?
How did Dr. Bright wind up apprehended by
the Red Right Hand while dressed in a Halloween
store Batman costume?
Well, it's a long story, but it all started
a few weeks ago...
You see, Dr. Bright was watching Justice League.
No, not that one.
No, not that one either.
He was watching the animated series from 2001.
He loved superhero cartoons, and always had
since he was a little kid.
Of course, he could barely remember his childhood
a lot of the time these days.
He wondered if that was a side effect of changing
bodies so many times, if his memories were
fading with each new host he took.
But then he shook off the thought and immersed
himself in a world of brightly colored costumes,
impossible feats of heroism, and adventures
in the fight against evil and injustice.
Things were simple here.
Things were safe.
If only his life could be like that, if he
could be some kind of superhero fighting alongside
a crew of other special individuals dedicated
to high-minded ideals like truth, justice,
and a better world for all.
But...why couldn't his life be like that?
What was stopping him from forming a Justice
League of his very own?
He was sad, lonely, and had no contact with
his immediate family.
He had tons of resources at his disposal,
even if most of those resources didn't technically
belong to him.
When he thought about it, there wasn't much
difference between him and Batman.
All he needed was a costume and a team, and
he already had last Halloween's outfit ready
to go in his closet.
But before he could recruit the rest of his
SCP Foundation Justice League, Dr. Bright
needed one more thing that Batman had, and
he didn't: a butler.
Fortunately, he knew exactly where to find
one.
He retrieved SCP-662 from its storage locker,
and shook it, producing a soft chime.
Immediately, Mr. Deeds appeared, ready to
attend to any task at hand.
"Good afternoon, Dr. Bright.
How may I be of service?"
The butler asked.
"Well, Mr. Deeds, you're going to help me
build a team..."
If Dr. Bright was Batman, then the first thing
he needed to do was identify his Superman.
Who could be the Man of Steel to his Caped
Crusader?
There was one obvious answer, really...A man
with metal arms and legs, who could withstand
any damage done to him.
It would have to be SCP-073, Cain.
While Mr. Deeds was pitching Cain on the idea,
Dr. Bright got to work on brainstorming his
next pick.
He needed someone with reality-warping powers,
someone who could make objects appear out
of thin air, teleport from one place to another.
There was no one he knew who could do that
better than God himself, SCP-343.
When presented with the chance to do battle
against the forces of evil, he was more than
willing to join the team.
While Dr. Bright was trying to decide on his
next chosen teammate, he received an unexpected
visitor.
Cactusman stopped by the Hall of Justice - also
known as Dr. Bright's office - and begged
to be given a place in the League.
He wasn't exactly a Martian or a Manhunter,
but this was Dr. Bright's own unique spin
on the old formula, so it couldn't hurt to
deviate just a little bit.
Besides, Cactusman looked so sad when he asked
to join in, and he couldn't say no to that
face.
Of course, Dr. Bright wasn't about to forget
his second favorite superhero, just behind
Batman.
He needed a Wonder Woman.
But who could compare to a super powerful
Amazon from an all-female island...
There wasn't anyone with a lasso of truth,
but he did know a perfectly sweet candidate.
She wouldn't be too thrilled to work with
a man, but when he offered to swap her nasty
sugar substitute meals for the real thing,
Ms. Sweetie was perfectly delighted to join
in.
He had dominion over land covered, but Dr.
Bright supposed he needed someone who could
handle more aquatic missions.
An adept swimmer, perhaps with the ability
to talk to fish, even command them.
He knew just the guy to talk to...
"You've got the wrong idea, pal."
Mr. Fish sighed.
"I don't have any special powers.
I'm just a guy from Boston.
With a fish head.
That's my whole bag.
Sorry."
Fortunately, Dr. Bright had a backup, so,
with Mr. Fish refusing to take part, he turned
to his second choice: SCP-054.
Who better to help with water-based conflicts
than someone made entirely out of water herself?
The final member of the team was SCP-2094,
Motormouth.
To be completely honest, Dr. Bright mainly
picked him because he was funny, and because
his name already kind of sounded like the
name of a superhero.
Was it shallow?
Yes.
Did Dr. Bright care?
Absolutely not.
Dr. Bright was so occupied with the task of
forming his League of heroes, that he didn't
stop to consider that every force for good
needs an equal opposite.
Just as you cannot have light without darkness,
it is also true that every hero needs a villain.
Enter Dr. Alto Clef.
As the day went on, Dr. Clef had caught wind
of his colleague's little plan, and decided
not to let Dr. Bright have all the fun.
He was forming a team of his own, a Legion
of Doom every bit as powerful, with a taste
for mischief and destruction.
He fancied himself the SCP Foundation's very
own Lex Luthor, a dapper genius with the necessary
power and leadership skills to run an eventual
evil empire.
After all, he’d already worked for the GOC
before working with the Foundation.
Maybe he should try his hand at being his
own diabolical boss for once.
He would be the brains of the operation, to
be sure, but he would need some muscle to
back him up.
Someone to help physically intimidate any
foes, to crush obstacles that might stand
in his way.
SCP-076-2, the immortal warrior known as Able,
would do nicely.
His superhuman strength, speed, and resilience
to pain and shock made for the perfect guy
to call on if the boss needed a steel door
ripped off its hinges, or someone to punch
through a concrete wall.
Dr. Clef had him flown in, and once Able was
presented with the promise of as much violence
as his bloodthirsty heart desired, he was
thrilled to call himself a member of the SCP
Legion of Doom.
Just as it had with Dr. Bright's plan, word
of Dr. Clef's nefarious scheme began to spread
like wildfire.
Naturally, he began to attract some volunteers.
That was to be expected.
What Dr. Clef did not expect, however, was
the sight of SCP-082, straining the seams
of a purple suit with his enormous stature,
a vivid green wig perched on top of his head.
His face was smeared with makeup, the white
base paint of a clown, and a wide, garish
red mouth.
"Do you want to know how I got these scars?"
He asked, with a wild cackle.
"Nice costume," Dr. Clef nodded approvingly.
"What costume?"
Fernand replied.
"It's me, I'm the Joker!
I finished destroying Gotham City like I wanted
to, all done with that, so I'm looking for
a new job.
Wanna see a magic trick?"
He pulled a pencil out of his pocket, and
Dr. Clef snatched it out of his hand.
"Not right now.
But come on in, let's make a little mayhem."
One of Dr. Clef's favorite villains of all
time was Two Face, a formerly good man fallen
from grace, transformed into a capricious
monster deciding a victim's fate with the
toss of a coin.
He didn't know anyone with two faces at the
Foundation, but he did know of one anomaly
that was capable of having any face in the
world- as long as it was beautiful.
A bit of flattery was enough to win over SCP-056,
though they still made it clear they were
joining out of the kindness of their heart.
"I'm far too good for this nonsense.
But I'm bored, so I'll give it a try anyway."
Next, Dr. Clef supplied the meanest mask around,
SCP-035, the Possessive Mask, with a special
treat: a temporary body, in the form of a
life-size action figure of The Riddler.
"Know any good riddles?"
He asked, as he placed the mask over the figure's
plastic face.
It grinned at him, black slime dripping from
its open mouth.
"The person who built it sold it.
The person who bought it never used it.
The person who used it never saw it.
What is it?"
Dr. Clef shrugged.
"Final hint: anyone who opposes me will end
up inside of one."
The mask's smile seemed to widen.
Dr. Clef laughed suddenly as the answer occurred
to him.
"A coffin."
This was going to be fun.
Wanting a man with a knowledge of medical
science on his side, not to mention a touch
that could stop a heart instantly, Dr. Clef
attempted to recruit the Plague Doctor.
But he wouldn't accept the offer, insisting
he had far too much work to attend to, and
that he would never want to join a team that
"the infernal mask" was part of in the first
place.
With both groups assembled, the SCP Justice
League and the SCP Legion of Doom, there was
only one thing left to do: let the two sides
battle it out, and see just who would triumph
in the end.
As Dr. Bright sat at the head of the table
in his Hall of SCP Justice, preparing to begin
the first official meeting of his super team,
a rock crashed through the window of the room.
Wrapped around it was a note, made from letters
cut out of magazines and pasted onto paper
to form new words.
"Come out and play."
A direct challenge from his new arch-nemesis,
no doubt.
There was no time to waste!
The team had to suit up and prepare to face
off against the forces of evil.
Dr. Bright pulled on his Batman costume, silently
cursing himself for not springing for the
real drivable Batmobile when he had the chance.
But now was not the time for Bat Regrets,
now was the time for action.
"Mr. Deeds!"
He rang the bell.
"Yes, sir?"
The butler appeared.
"Please fetch the rest of
the team their uniforms."
Within moments, they were dressed for action
in the technicolor attire
of bona fide superheroes.
Sure, some costumes were too small, others
were too large, and Cactusman's spikes kept
poking holes in the spandex, but Dr. Bright
thought they all looked perfect.
The SCP Justice League burst into the SCP
Legion of Doom Headquarters, formerly known
as the canteen, where they found Dr. Clef
and his army baddies waiting.
"Riddle me this..."
The mask called out.
"The poor have it.
The rich need it.
If you eat it, you die.
And it is the only thing that can stop me...What
is it?"
"Oh, I know the answer!"
Fernand piped up.
"It's nothing!"
"Well, aren't you clever," A Beautiful Person
snarked.
"I was promised I would get to do some stabbing."
Able growled.
"Ready to give up now, Bright?"
Dr. Clef asked.
"Never!"
Dr. Bright cried.
And what was perhaps the most bizarre, petty,
and unnecessary battle
between a pair of manchildren
and their home-grown super squads began.
Dr. Bright and Dr. Clef themselves were, of
course, at the front lines, engaging in a
somewhat embarrassing bare-knuckle brawl on
the dirty tile floor.
Nearby, their violent army began duking it
out on their behalfs.
Fernand, still dressed as the Joker, began
duking it out with Cain, who tried to encourage
the giant cannibal to take a non-violent route.
Fernand, true to his diabolical costume’s
spirit, didn’t listen to reason, and instead
tried to bite Cain.
This was a terrible move, as Fernand quickly
realized, when his own bite marks began appearing
on the fabric of his cheap purple suit.
This did not stop him from trying again, and
again, and again…
Next came the obligatory superhero movie cliche
of the two token female supers pairing off
to fight each other in a way that feels oddly
condescending.
SCP-056 was duking it out with the Water Nymph
and Miss Sweetie, whose diabolical ability
to make others feel terrible about themselves
through relentless oneupmanship was being
blunted by the Water Nymph and Miss Sweetie
bolstering each other’s self-esteem with
compliments and mutual emotional support.
Eventually, this frustrated SCP-056 so much
that she got frustrated and stormed away,
like the unpleasant, entitled bully she is.
Meanwhile, despite the fact that Cactusman
was fighting valiantly, the evil powers of
SCP-035 were too much for him.
The mask was wrapping its stolen hands around
Cactusman’s thorny throat and squeezing,
slowly making it harder for him to breathe.
The Mask gave an evil cackle and said, “Silly
little boy, playing hero.
What a waste of a life.
Don’t worry, boy - As one of my hosts, you’ll
finally be part of something worthwhile!”
“I’ll never give in to you, villain!”
Cactusman chokes out.
“You don’t have a choice, my boy!”
the Mask gloated.
“We always have a voice,” said a calm,
fatherly voice - the voice of SCP-343.
With a flick of his immensely powerful wrist,
035 was sent sailing across the room, whacking
him against the wall.
His melting host body splattered from the
impact, and the Mask clattered down to the
ground.
“Drat!”
the Mask yelled.
“Foiled again!”
Able was having an extremely frustrating battle
with Motormouth.
He produced a plethora of obsidian blades
from his pocket dimensions and began tossing
them at the anomalous carny at incredible
speeds.
However, Able was not aware that, in addition
to Motormouth’s ability to stretch his jaw
and shamelessly swallow anything, his time
with Herman Fuller’s Circus of the Disquieting
had also made him an expert juggler.
He was able to catch each of Able’s blades,
and swallow them effortlessly.
“Stop doing that!”
Able fumed.
“It's dishonorable!”
With chaos unfolding all around them, Dr.
Bright and Dr. Clef stopped fighting to take
in the majesty of their co-created travesty.
SCPs kicking the tar out of each other all
over the Site-19 canteen.
It was truly something to behold, and certainly
a fun way to kill an afternoon.
"You know..."
Dr. Clef locked eyes with Dr. Bright.
"We're not so different, you and I..."
But before he could finish the rest of his
truly epic speech, an armed guard kicked down
the door, and the members of MTF Alpha-1,
The Red Right Hand, began pouring into the
room.
They tackled Dr. Bright and Dr. Clef to the
ground, and set about neutralizing any other
threats in the room.
Some anomalies returned to their containment
chambers willingly, like Fernand, sprinting
down the hall at a surprisingly fast pace
and insisting "It was peer pressure, you see!
I never wanted to!"
Others, like Able, refused to back down, slashing
his sword wildly and taking out a dozen guards
before he was recontained.
So, we find ourselves back where we started:
with a whim in the shape of the Bat Signal,
with a moment of great triumph, followed by
a swift descent into failure, and a Mobile
Task Force member putting Dr. Clef in handcuffs.
Luckily, the two Doctors wouldn't be thrown
into Arkham for letting their imaginations
get the better of them.
Though their egos - and bodies - were a bit
bruised, they would be free to fight another
day.
O5-1, the long-suffering Chairman of the O5
Council, released a memo regarding the matter,
which was delivered to both Dr. Bright and
Dr. Clef during their disciplinary hearings.
We’ll allow that memo to play us out.
“I wish I could even say I was surprised.
Did your mothers not hug you enough as children?
Did people not pay enough attention to you?
Jack, Alto, to the best of my knowledge you
are a pair of grown bloody men, working for
the most powerful and vital
anti-anomaly organization
in the world - where you, terrifyingly, have
positions of considerable influence.
Act like it!
And please know that if I catch wind of anything
like this happening again, I will have both
of you encased in cement.
Now…
Get back to work, you idiots!”
Now go check out “SCP Edition - Weirdest
Things on Amazon - Dr Bright's Great Idea!”
and “HILARIOUS List of Things Dr. Bright
is Not Allowed to Do!” for more wacky antics
from the lovably deranged Dr. Bright!